Hansel and Gretel were the children of a poor woodcutter.
Their family was very hungry...
...so the stepmother convinced her husband to abandon the children in the forest.
Hansel and Gretel heard her plan and gathered white pebbles to leave themselves a trail home.
After their return, the stepmother again convinced her husband to abandon them.
This time, however, they could only leave bread crumbs to mark a path back to their home.
Unfortunately, the various animals of the woods ate their trail of bread crumbs.
Lost in the forest, they found a house made of candies.
An old woman lived there.
She was a witch and fed them lots of food, to fatten them up and eat them.
Days passed by, and Hansel grew very fat, as she wished.
She told Gretel to climb into an oven to be sure it is ready to bake.
But Gretel guessed that the witch intended to bake her.
So she tricked the witch into climbing into the oven, closing it behind her.
Then, they took some jewels and food and ran home.
They were reunited with their father and lived happily ever after.